la russie est arrivée grande première
dans la course vaccin contre le kobe 19
loin devant tous les autres
dès le mois d'août spoutnik v s'est
présenté au public un vaccin qui ne
portent pas n'importe quel nom puisqu'il
rend hommage au premier satellite envoyé
dans l'espace par l'urss en 1957 notre
commune aux yeux d'après ce que je sais
ce matin un premier vaccin contre la
nouvelle infection de coronavirus a été
enregistré pour la première fois dans le
monde
bien que je sache qu'il fonctionne de
manière très efficace en créant une
immunité stable je répète qu'il a passé
tous les essais nécessaires au 10 mai le
méchant vladimir poutine qui annonce
quelques mois seulement après le début
de la pandémie que son pays a réussi à
produire le tout premier vaccin contre
un virus qui a mis le monde à l'arrêt ça
ne passe pas auprès de la presse
occidentale et française qui fait tout
pour le décrédibiliser un effet
d'annoncé qui n'a aucun sens
manipuler l'information autour de la
vaccination comme le fait monsieur
poutine est de mon point de vue
absolument irresponsable un homme
politique comme l'a dit mr poutine à la
volonté d'apparaître à la pointe de la
science mais ni lui ni son pays ne le
sont mais c'est quoi cette histoire de
vaccins en russie un vaccin cela met
généralement une dizaine d'années à être
découverts et testé une fraude des
données donc possible presque il ya
aussi du mal à prononcer correctement le
nom de spoutnik v questions sur le bac
soit russan weepu tni sq 5s pique nique
et puis et puis il y a spoutnik 5 le
vaccin russe étude qui concerne le
fameux vaccin russe smic 5
et pourtant on dit bien spoutnik v v
comme vaccin à vecteur viral ça fait
beaucoup devaient aimer ça peut servir
de repères mes mots techniques
autrefois décrié spoutnik v est
aujourd'hui sous le feu des projecteurs
et il pourrait être utilisée plus
largement en europe
pourquoi pour plusieurs raisons la
première nous renvoie vers la dernière
étude du land 7 la prestigieuse revue
britannique scientifiques affirment que
le vaccin russe est efficace à 91,6 %
entre le kobe de 19
des conclusions validé par des experts
indépendants
spoutnik vais à ferait partie des
vaccins les plus performants du marché
vaccins à deux doses bon marché faciles
à produire et à acheminer les résultats
rapportés sont claires et le principe
scientifique de cette vaccination est
démontrée ce qui veut dire qu'un vaccin
supplémentaire peut désormais rejoindre
le combat pour réduire l'incidence du
coffee de 19 et de la place il y en a
pour un vaccin supplémentaire parce que
les vaccins manque que les livraisons
promises par les laboratoires en janvier
n'ont pas toutes été honoré les moyens
de production ne suffisent pas en effet
à fabriquer rapidement la quantité de
vaccins nécessaires
la commission européenne qui négocie au
nom des 27 pays membres de l'union
avaient précommandé quelques deux
milliards deux cent mille doses auprès
de six fournisseurs bruxelles qui
tablaient sur la livraison de 100
millions de doses au premier trimestre
non a reçu qu'un peu plus de 18 millions
au 1er février
face à cette pénurie l'allemagne ouvre
la voie aux vaccins russe la chancelière
angela merkel se dit même prête à
soutenir la russie dans sa demande
d'autorisation auprès de l'agencé
européenne des médicaments
toute personne qui demande à l'agencé
médicale européenne une approbation est
la bienvenue
j'en ai parlé avec le président russe
tout vaccin est le bienvenu dans l'union
européenne mais seul celui qui apporte
les données nécessaires de l'agencé
européenne du médicament sera approuvée
même l'exécutif français qui s'étaient
montrés distant vis-à-vis du vaccin rush
se montre aujourd'hui un peu plus
intéressé on a vu aujourd'hui des
publications qui semble indiquer une
très forte efficacité du vaccin spoutnik
mais nous ne pouvons pas le distribuer
en france tant que le producteur russe
n'a pas soumis une autorisation de mise
sur le marché à nos autorités
et c'est normal c'est une question de
responsabilité sanitaires à la minute où
il la dépose rats dans les meilleurs
délais les autorités européennes et avec
quelle chacune deux autorités nationales
évidemment regarderont scientifique
man de manière indépendante ce vaccin
est en fonction de ses résultats et des
preuves
le mot lowbrow ou pas spoutnik wc déjà
un milliard de doses de précommander à
travers le monde et des pays comme la
hongrie l'iran la corée du sud ou encore
l'argentine qui l'ont déjà adopté